leute was geht ab hier ist ein maxi
kommen zu einer runde survival games in
einer challenge zusammen mit meinem
bruder escape oder wir machen heute eine
lustige people's theater völker eine
challenge da führen wir diese pralinen
hier die keinen näheren namen haben also
sicher war halt einfach heute da war
heute ist weihnachten nach berlin
gekommen und haben gesagt okay vergessen
wir die challenge weil wir sonst
eigentlich ziehen lassen die
folgendermaßen sowie spielen abwechselnd
eine runde sg und während der eine
spielt muss der andere der gerade nicht
spielt für jeden kehl den der spielten
macht sich eine praline in den mund
stecken und drin war und drin bereit ist
dass er dafür nicht count eigentlich
darf darf nicht kaum und musste über die
ganze runde warten kommt er wieder raus
oder ja da kommst du darauf so heiß und
maxis macht muss ich abwarten schwert
drei pralinen können kelek des todes und
umgekehrt und für die runde der dauer
der runde hat es ja gedauert das erst am
ende kommt also eine besonders kleine im
fall etwas mit dem thema los herbert
tiemann name das ist in los angeles der
an und fährt als ein polizist
lange diese pralinen gold so leute da
sind wir auch in der runde von meinem
bruder ich hoffe mal die wird genauso
schlecht wie meine ich bei euch hell
kurz nicht die junge ich war gerade auf
den ekligen hotkeys draußen
max hat damit neben shift und steuerung
aus normaler hotkey leiste und da war
ich gerade eben als ich versuchte mich
mit shift los zu sprechen
ja ich habe ich bin auf chefs so muss es
sein auch füssens werfen
natürlich habe ich auch ein bisschen
hunger optimismus aber muss aber nichts
heißen konnte das tier aber nicht essen
erstmals sein erstes tor bei den calgary
flames lag ja irgendwas passt es für
rosberg gar nicht er eigentlich in
ordnung
naja ist nun schwer schwert das in
ordnung aber sonst nicht locker ist
jetzt kommt ja das ist richtig dortmann
61 punkte school 107 halbjahr also quasi
einen rüstungs und unter eisen erfordern
könnte der erste gegner sein der elcom
rüstung hat vielleicht hat er es
entscheidet die schwerter nicht kommen
könnte seien junge alles gute mit irland
mussten hat ganz weh getan und im rennen
und sehr schön happig und die erste pole
für dich ja wohl denn die bahn 500 alter
das richtig nahe weil ich wir gucken ob
ich den ersten teil noch einen kegel
kommen ja aber ich ich da jetzt nicht
angesagt dafür suche ich wollte wieder
in die lava locken
das wäre ja hier noch ein dickes wieder
habe ich bekommen
wie groß sind ist mehr los
da ist er dann schon mehr bekommen
der stellen nicht sehr passend holte
noch einen schönen pakets jetzt richtig
welches equipment to save her weil ein
bisschen haben wir erst überholt in der
heute kommt muss mich mit ihm
nein ein alter nicht mit ja komfortabler
macht mich zu dem bus mich zudem egal
egal wenn ich jetzt sterben mussten
neben nee nee nee nee nee ich weiß nicht
mertesacker mertesacker am herd ackern
müssen das akzeptieren
von apa dpa oder pippi petersen neuer
der liga einfach produziert
der will der wird ihn denke ich mal
meint sind nervös was machen
er will das wieder ins haben es kein
laufwerk ist gefühlt nach tokio erwartet
oder wald gar keine chance
mit diesem equipment echte waffe
deutlich schlechtere rüstung als ob
keine ich habe ihn sehr schön
der ghanaer war vollkommen ungefährlich
deswegen hat die tanz zu lassen ok sehr
gut danke und noch hatte dritte praline
für dich wie fühlt sich dann am ende
kaum über 3 wird erschwert
der muss in die lava und einzige chance
alle alle natürlich auch wieder teile
des todes selbstverständlich hatte und
das nehme ich erst mal die challenge
verbiete das ist übrigens richtig kann
viele vereine denn man kommt ja
versammelt sich das extrem viel speicher
und ist doch soll es nicht so bitter
einem ein goldstück gleich kaputt
nein mein goldstück kaputte mister
mertesacker hd kann aber zu mir kommen
nein nein der staat nicht mit der ist
lob der sockel alter diesel rain stecker
als leiter martin geholt machen
am ende war ich den bau metall alles
kann und das war es von der pralinen ski
challenge vera lynns gekentert dass die
mit entdecken oder mach's gut
t